hi I'm Kristin Ritter and I played
Jessica Jones hi my name is Charlie Cox
I play Matt Murdoch aka daredevil hi I'm
Quinn Jones I'm playing Danny Rand aka
iron fist hi Mike Colter okay Luke Cage
and you're in the set of our
Entertainment Weekly cover shoot the
following program modern style Jessica
is sort of an anti superhero so what
makes her a hero at the end of the day
is that she'll stick up to the little
guy and he will protect the people that
she loves I think one of the reasons
that daredevil is such an interesting
superhero is because he's one of the few
severus that has a disability so he was
blinded as a young child and the result
of that accident he has developed their
superhuman senses Luke age is a man was
wrongly convicted of a crime that he did
not commit in prison he basically got a
plethora of superpowers that he did not
ask for so now he's trying to manage his
life and hopefully incorporate that into
his life and become a man and a
superhero at the same time the iron fist
is like an energy force and certain
people once they're trained up in a
certain way are able to channel it and
harness it and Danny Rand is one of them
I'm not entirely sure how Matt fixin to
the defend JEP I can't wait to see how
he deals with those characters I think
both Matt Murdock and Jessica Jones are
quite opinionated and quite stubborn
imagine that would be a kind of a fiery
relationship in a good way Jessica Jones
is very reluctant to exist in the world
let alone use her superpowers so Jessica
fits in very again reluctantly Luke Cage
is a unique guy because he's still
finding himself and so hopefully and his
defenders you'll start to see him start
to you know set down some roofs again so
Danny Rand is is he's the one that knows
really what's going on
he knows how serious the situation is
since the end of students who of
daredevil
something's going to have to change in
him whereby he's willing to accept help
he's willing to be part of a team Danny
Randy he's the one that kind of derived
the group
to get done really it's hard for someone
who doesn't want to be a part of any
social circles to have to you know
participate in just like group activity
so she brings her attitude and her
biting sense of humor I think Luke Cage
is the most centered of the group so
hopefully when things have to happen he
thinks about it twice and he starts
starts to use his wisdom I think that's
what he brings to the group
[Music]
friend
oh you think the four of you can save
New York you can't even save yourselves
hey youtubers it's Charlie so they
dropped a whole bunch of defenders bombs
we learn a little bit about the
characters in the story so let's break
it down there is a new round of the
spider-man giveaway it's a $20
comiXology gift card all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything so the
behind-the-scenes is kind of fun but we
actually got some more pictures and some
information on the cast of villains
Sigourney Weaver's character so I'll
explain all that stuff number 5 when is
this actually coming they confirmed a
summer release which means the very end
of May or June they have announced the
exact day but it's always on a Friday
there are 8 episodes instead of 13
they're calling it a miniseries instead
of like a new season whatever that just
means that there are only eight episodes
there will be a season two of defenders
but it just depends on how fast they
cycle through the following seasons of
daredevil like there'll be another
season of daredevil Jessica Jones Luke
Cage they'll keep going with all these
series so eventually they'll do the
Avenger cycle where they come back
around for another defenders team-up but
Wonder Woman is being released the first
weekend in June and if you remember last
year they released daredevil season 2
the weekend before Batman vs Superman
came out in March so they might do the
same thing but they'll probably wait
till after iron fist comes out to start
talking more about the defenders so
right now they're mostly promoting that
iron fist starts March 17th so of course
I'll be doing all kinds of videos for
that but when they were promoting all
this defender stuff they said that there
are three Netflix series coming this
year sort of unofficially confirming
that we'll see The Punisher by the end
of the year so number four if you forgot
about the Punisher series they've been
shooting that for a while now it sounds
like if they can get it done in time
it'll be November or December release
that might change they're not going to
announce the release date for a while
but they'll probably bring it to Comic
Cons will be like a big punisher panel
usually the comic-con panels that they
do for the Netflix series
it's whichever series is coming next and
then they'll have all the other people
come to so they'll be like a little
stuff from all the other series we'll
drop a bunch of footage like we did last
year
but mostly it'll probably be a Punisher
panel daredevil Jessica Jones or Lou
Cates first season was your favorite
favorite I like them all I like them all
there I mean defenders yeah but number
three what's going on with defenders
what's the story who is the villain so
Sigourney Weaver was confirmed as the
villain they're just calling her
Alexandra that's all they said she
doesn't have horns they only have this
one picture she's supposed to be this
crazy badass the way the showrunner was
hyping her up was by saying Sigourney is
the kind of person you can buy as the
smartest person in the room who you can
also buy as a person holding a
flamethrower talking about her aliens
character Ripley her character is a very
powerful force in New York City she's
everything Sigourney is sophisticated
intelligent in dangerous so that just
makes it sound like she's not an alien
like there's not some secret visit under
her she's just a really powerful morally
grey human being person meaning does
that probably have something to do with
the IgH company so way back last year
Jeff lobe who's the president of Marvel
TV was talking about the iron fist
series in how he fits into all this
talking about Big Pharma's influence in
New York City like you have the
street-level heroes daredevil dealing
with the hand this mystical war of light
but then you also have like the really
rich people in New York City like the
Tony Stark level people trying to
control everything so that's really
where Iron Fist comes in so we'll
probably learn a lot more about what's
going on with this evil companies IgH
company in the Iron Fist series but we
do know that Luke Cage was sent back to
Seagate prison you get a little bit of
that story in these photos Jessica Jones
and daredevil team up to try and get him
out the legal way that's probably where
jeryn hogarth comes in - there's some
other pictures after Luke Cage gets out
with misty Knight here so we know that
she's going to be there separately we
don't see them all together and in
either behind the scenes photos yet but
iron fist and Colleen wing will guest
star so some of the really big
supporting characters from all the
different series will also guest star
and defenders so stick is going to be
big part of defenders notably they've
left
Punisher off the official cast list but
they were shooting Punisher at the same
time as they were shooting defenders
Jeph Loeb said that they were basically
shooting all these series at the same
time so he was bouncing back and forth
between the sets in New York City if
defender says it's happening in New York
City
Punisher stuff is happening in New York
City it makes sense that there would be
some element of crossover so number two
what about the Punisher why is he not
officially a defender well mostly I
think because it's not in his nature to
team up with a lot of other people he
doesn't really hang out with the
Avengers in the comics he's kind of
anti-social he is a good person but he's
just one of those characters
that's so hardcore and so extreme that
the other heroes don't really want him
around like they're not really happy to
have the Punishers help but they always
do appreciate it when he does them a
solid so like the Punisher is very
important but he's much more of a
background player we have seen pictures
of him on the set with Karen's page so
we know there's going to be characters
from the other series on the Punisher it
just remains to be seen how he helps
them out during the defenders so just
don't expect to see him in any of the
official marketing materials for
defenders in the way they marketed him
during daredevil season 2 but he was all
over the daredevil season two trailers
the promotional photos all that stuff
just don't expect the same treatment in
defenders but number one when are we
actually going to see some footage
typically what they do is they tease the
next series at the very end of each new
season so like at the end of Luke Cage
you sort of get a teaser for Iron Fist
they'll probably do the same thing with
defenders so the Iron Fist series will
lead directly into defenders we'll
probably see some elements of the plot
it's circling back around where you see
Easter eggs from the other series like
they might tease the IgH company again
which is like the big pharma company
that's controlling these military people
it performed the experiments that gave
Jessica Jones her powers in the purple
man so they just have their hand in
everything that like this evil shadow
corporation much more so than the hand
which you actually know as villains like
they are definitely very bad but part of
Sigourney Weaver's character is is that
she doesn't operate from the shadows
like she's standing out here on this
like she commands respect from everyone
in the city she can be as bad as she
wants and it doesn't matter it's kind of
a kingpin type situation so I know
that's another big question will the
kingpin be in defenders maybe a little
bit but just like the Punisher he's not
on the official cast list so he'll
probably have some background role but
right now he's slowly building his power
base consolidating all the gangs in the
city so I'm not really expecting him to
become full-blown kingpin until we get
to daredevil season 3 which will either
be like 2018 maybe 2019 I'm hoping it
drops in 2018 so let me know what do you
guys most hype about whole bunch of Iron
Fist coming really soon so I'll say
congratulations to the newest spider-man
giveaway winner John Ramone you win a
$20.00 comiXology gift card be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details whole bunch of footage just
dropped so I'll try to get through it as
fast as possible there's a bunch of
comic book dues so legends of tomorrow
footage in probably Star Wars Episode 8
but I'll be posting updates on Twitter
and Facebook on web videos are coming
will you guys wait for that you can
click here to watch the Justice League
Green Lantern teaser to learn all about
the Green Lantern movie and you can
click here for the Iron Fist trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight